Ladies and gentlemen, you might be asking yourself,
what has Alex Jones so upset right now?
What is going on? I've never seen him like,
as I've been as media buyer for a very long time,
I've never seen a big upset. I think I might have the answer guys.
It's because I recently showed him a clip of copycat Kevin Davidson.
What is up guys? And welcome back to another exciting video.
That's right. Ladies and gentlemen,
Kevin David is back to stealing content on the internet.
Look at this lady three months ago, she did a video that did pretty well.
How I made three K in a week and Kevin David is back. Just ripping it off.
Completely.
Check it out. Either you are out of work. Maybe you're out of work,
selling old clothes, old clothing or shoes on Poshmark
[inaudible] and parcel.
Now this is nothing new. We've known copycat Kevin for a very long time.
I've talked about him in the past. Okay?
I'm not bringing this up to tell you about copycat. Kevin,
I'm bringing you up to talk about his son. That's right. Kevin,
David has children and I'm not talking about literally has children.
I'm saying he's got a bunch of many MES running around because when we don't
crack down on plagiarism,
but we don't have any consequences for stealing content. Well,
there's going to be problems.
You're going to have problems in the ecosystem because people are going to see
that they're going to see, Hey, Kevin,
David's just stealing people's content and just rewording it a little bit to try
to make it his own. I mean, but it's still plagiarism. And he's got 1.1,
5 million subscribers because his audience is too dumb to realize what's going
on. So people are going to try to go out and copy what he's doing.
They're going to copy the copier, right? It's a,
it's a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy.
And that is who I want to talk about today. There's a,
there's a new guru on the block trying to copy Kevin David's copycat strategy.
And I've got, got to nip it in the buddy air, snip, snip names, Richard, you,
before he gets too powerful. Look at this kid.
He's already got 114,000 subscribers. Let's check out his content, right? Okay.
How I tricked my brain, like to like doing hard things. Okay.
This video is a copy.
See if you type it in there's a guy who already did this video.
He did it very successfully. 2 million views.
So this guy saw it copied the exact title.
And then look at the video itself. Here's the first one.
Video to answer this question,
we need to look at this brain neurotransmitter dopamine.
Now let's see what Richard.
So the fundamental concept here that I need for you to understand is actually
this neurotransmitter called dopamine.
Dopamine is often considered a pleasure molecule.
Dopamine is what makes us desire things.
And it's that desire that gives us the motivation to get up and do stuff.
It's a pleasure.
Motivation, desire. Let's see what Richard us.
Dopamine is typically associated with pleasure as well as motivation,
more specifically desire. This is just.
Shameless, man. And it's all from Kevin David. He pioneered the Hey,
all you do is you copy the transcript and then you slightly reword it to try to
pretend it's your own. And you just it as if it's your own idea,
you're not reworking them. You're not being inspired.
You're just taking the entire structure of the idea and you're ripping it right
off, but guys, it doesn't stop there. That's right. I'm I bring the value.
Okay. It gets even worse. Richard's not the only one.
Now people are doing it to Sam ovens. Somebody sent me this.
This is a famous ad of Sam ovens. That a lot of people are apparently stealing.
He goes, Hey, it's Sam ovens here. I'm not an author speaker investor. In fact,
I have zero Lamborghini, zero jets, zero stages spoken on. Here's what I do.
I have two products, eight figures and annual figure zero debt, one Forbes,
30 under 30 blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So what do people do?
This guy has a successful idea. What do they do? Well, check out this idiot.
Hey, it's Dickson robot care. I'm not an author.
Speaker software company or marketing agency.
In fact I have zero Pennsy zero Aerojet zero stages spoken on. [inaudible] copy.
Copy. Copy. Copy. Got me. And here's what I do.
I have three successful fitness facilities, 14 years in the game.
Seven figures in Arabic. He just copies it right off.
Here's another one of these idiots, big little gyms. Hey will Hearst here.
I'm not a speaker author or a software company. In fact,
I have zero Lamborghini's Aerojet zero stage of smoking on zero social media
presence. Zero. Here's what I do have two micro gyms launch,
10 years in the game. Seven figures, annual revenue. Hey,
you steal and get an original idea. These people, I swear.
They don't have any ideas for themselves.
They're recycling and recycling and recycling and recycling.
These are not people you want to copy because there are a copy of the copy of
the copy of the copy. This is not how you build a brand. They go, Hey,
that's a good idea. Let me the yank. Let me yank it.
If you see someone copies something and it's blatant, you know what I mean?
We're talking literal, yanking it. If you see someone yank,
you gotta head out the back door. Dude, unsubscribed, Inc. Oops,
North flow consulting. Not going to happen.
How do you think they're going to help you? They want to be your coach.
What are they going to teach you?
If they're literally copying another coach and that coach probably copied
another coach.
It's a copy of a copy of a copy.
A plagiarism has gone too far and I, for one blame, Kevin, David,
was he the start of it? Probably not, but I blame him. I blame him. Nonetheless.
I don't know whose fault it is guys. You know that,
but at some point the buck has to stop. So I dunno,
maybe it's not a red flag to everyone, but for me when I see stuff like this,
blatant stealing I'm out anyway, that's all for now. Thanks for watching.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
You need to perform a dopamine detox.
[inaudible].